مذهب معكم للاردن سالنا الناس هناك هل
تثقون بمنشورات وحسابات الاطباء على مواقع
التواصل متابع
تجربه
يعني اي شخص بده يسوق لاعلان الى موقع
التواصل راح يعملوا كفضل اشي بالنسبه له
بفضل اني اروح دايركت على الطبيب مش انه
عن طريق اعلان او كذا او او اسمع من اشخاص
مقربين لالي عن الموضوع انه هذا فعلا هذا
الطبيب منيح او لا ثقه كامله لا الواحد
لازم يتاكد من المعلومات يعني مش ياخذ
الشيء بشكل دائري لانه خلص علوم حكيها
طبيب على مواقع التواصل انه يتاك ايه
ياخدها كام ليه لا لازم يتاكد يستشير
الطبي بشكل شخص لانه مش كل الشغلات بتكون
بشكل عام على كل الناس لا لازم كل شيء
شخصي في حاله المريض انه يتاكد من المريض
من الطبيب مشاكل
تروحي تجرب بس تعطي مفعول اكسده الموضوع
اللي بيحكوا ف- همم لازم يعني نتاكد منه
اكثر هسه بالنسبه للمستحضرات همم لا لانه
المستحضرات همم في اشياء اثار جانبيه ممكن
اتاثر عن مريض عنده مرض معين غير المرض
اللي هو بده ياخذ لاجل الدواء يكون عنده
ضغط او سكر او شيء فلازم مراجعه طبيب او
صيدلاني بالنسبه للدكاتره اللي همم اذا
كانوا موافقين وبنشروا عن شيء معين في
مواد طبيعيه ممكن تساعدني بدون ما اروح
طبيب اه ممكن اثق فيها اه لا في نفس الوقت
من حسب مين بدك تنشر هذه البروشه يعني في
دكاتره لهم اسمهم في السوق والناس تعرفهم
في دكاتره الناس ما بتعرفهم فجاه من
الاقيهم على السوشيال ميديا مشهورين
وعندهم كثير وارز ما بنعرف كيف صارت هاي
الشغله وممكن لا يمكن شيرين
مش لا يصلح ان يكون دكتور خيال هناك